can I get an American Horror Story  update next season what's coming what's  the theme do we know anything I have a  clue I think I'm an alcoholic I don't  know where why you know would turn would  maybe so but you're gonna be there and  you're I'm gonna be there awesome much I  do know Angela Bassett and her husband  Courtney be vants are both crushing it  in the Ryan Murphy TV world Angela on  American Horror Story and Courtney on  the People vs OJ Simpson I want to see  you guys come together on a show you  yeah you're in the same light women  you're in the same like family now  adversaries I would see that is when  thank you know you're like on the same  team lovey dovey not worrisome no no no  it you guys take that home after a day  kill each other unset mmm that was good  day babe fingers crossed but first you  could see Angela and gerard butler in  London has fallen march forth